CHRISTINE BREINER: Welcome
back to recitation.
In this video, I'd like
us to do the following two
problems, both related to
the same position vector.
So we're starting off with
a position vector defined
as r of t is equal to 1 minus
2 t squared i plus t squared
j plus negative 2
plus 2 t squared k.
So that's our position
vector, and I'd
like us to do the
following two things.
And you'll notice this
problem is pretty much
just a computational problem.
We're going to make
sure that we know
what these things I'm
about to talk about are,
how you define them, and how
you get from the position vector
to each of these things.
So we want to compute
the velocity, the speed,
the acceleration, and find the
unit tangent vector for r of t.
And then, the
second part, we want
to compute the arc length of the
trajectory from t equals 0 to t
equals 2.
So I'll give you a moment
to do that problem.
Why don't you pause the
video, work on the problem.
When you're ready to check your
work, bring the video back up
and I'll show you how I do it.
OK, welcome back.
Well, hopefully, you felt
comfortable with answering
these questions.
So now I will answer them and
you can compare your answers
with mine.
So let me start off with part a.
Part a, the first
thing we're going to do
is find the velocity.
So velocity is
really-- all we need
to do is take the derivative
of the position vector
with respect to t.
So I'm just going to
take r prime of t.
And now I'm going to write
it in the shorthand notation
that you've seen, with the
brackets to denote that it's
not a point, but it's a vector.
So this is what
you've seen to denote
a vector rather than a point.
So the derivative with respect
to t of the first component
is just negative 4t.
The derivative with respect
to t of the second component
is just 2t, because
we had t squared,
so when we take its
derivative, we just get 2t.
And the third component was
negative 2 plus 2 t squared,
so when I take its
derivative, I get a 4t,
so that is actually v of t, OK?
And then the next
thing I asked you
to do is determine the speed,
and the speed, of course,
is just the length of the
velocity vector, right?
So we just need to find the
length of v. Now, to do that,
to remind ourselves
what we do for that,
we actually take the
inner product of v
with itself, the dot
product of v with itself,
and then we take the
square root of that.
So let's look at what
the dot product will be.
Let me find the
squared thing first,
and then I will take
the square root.
So v dotted with v,
the first component
I'm going to have negative
4t quantity squared,
so that's going to
be 16 t squared.
And then the second
component is going
to be 2t quantity
squared, so I'm
going to have plus 4 t squared.
And the third component
is going to be
another-- it's going to
be 4t quantity squared,
so I get another 16 t squared.
So when I add those up, I
believe I get 36 t squared?
Yes, good.
And so then, I just have to take
the square root of both sides
to get what the speed
actually is instead
of the square of the speed.
So I get 6t, OK?
So that's the velocity;
that's the speed.
Now I need to find
the acceleration
and I need to find the
unit tangent vector.
OK, so let me see.
I will come over here.
Let me step off here and I
will find the acceleration
and the unit tangent vector.
So the acceleration,
if you remember,
the acceleration is
actually just the derivative
of the velocity
with respect to t.
So the acceleration
is going to be
the derivative of negative
4t is just negative 4.
The derivative of 2t is just
2, and the derivative of 4t
is just 4, all
with respect to t.
OK.
So the acceleration vector is
equal to negative 4 comma 2
comma 4, so you
see this actually
has constant acceleration.
So at any point,
your acceleration
is always this value,
so it's not surprising
that our velocity is
increasing, and actually, it's
increasing-- you'll notice,
each of these components
is constant.
The velocity, each of
the components is linear,
and if we went back, we
look at the position vector,
each of those
components is quadratic.
And this is exactly
what you expect
from just your
understanding of derivatives
in single-variable calculus.
If you start off with a constant
and you find an antiderivative,
it's going to be linear, and
you find another antiderivative,
you're going to
have a quadratic,
so we shouldn't be
surprised by any of that.
Now we have one more
thing to do with Part a,
and that is to find the
unit tangent vector.
And that's fairly easy,
because all we have to do
is-- if you notice, we
have the velocity vector
and we have its length.
And so to find the
unit tangent vector,
all we have to do
is take the velocity
and divide it by its length,
and that will normalize it.
That means that its length
will be one at that point,
because you're taking a
vector, dividing by its length,
so the length of the new vector
will have to be length one.
So let me write that down.
And actually, I guess the
point to remember here
is that the velocity vector
is tangent to the path you're
carving out, to the trajectory.
OK, so this is a vector.
This is a scalar.
So I'm going to take
1 over 6t, and I'm
going to multiply it
by negative 4t, 2t, 4t,
and this gives me,
when I do my division,
looks like it gives me a
negative 2/3, right, 1/3, 2/3.
So that is the unit
tangent vector, OK?
OK, and now, we have one
more point we want to make,
and that is having
to do with the arc
length of the trajectory.
That was the second
part of this problem,
was to find the arc length
of the trajectory from t
equals 0 to t equals 2.
So let me just draw
another line here.
And what we want to do
there then is-- really
what we want to do is we want
to integrate the speed, right?
We want to integrate
the speed from 0 to 2.
So this-- let me come over
here-- this absolute v,
you might have also seen
it written as ds/dt, right?
And so we want to
integrate this in dt--
in t, sorry-- from 0 to 2.
And so we come over here.
We want to integrate
from 0 to 2, 6t dt.
That's fairly easy.
That's going to be 6 t squared
over 2, evaluated from 0 to 2.
And so when I write
that down, I'm
going to get 6 times 4
divided by 2, 24 divided by 2,
I just get 12, and
the other term is 0.
So the arc length
is-- of the trajectory
from 0 to 2 is just 12 units.
So this really was a purely
computational type of problem.
All we were doing, if
you come back over here
and you recall what
we were trying to do,
is we started off with
a position vector.
We just did a lot
of computation.
We found the velocity, the
speed, the acceleration,
the unit tangent
vector, and then
we just wanted to find the
arc length of the trajectory.
So this is all
very computational,
but just to make
sure we understood
what all the terms
meant and how they
were related to one another.
So I'll stop there.